yeah I understand I am putting a certain
perception but that's the whole point of
the game you want huh no it's not the
point of the game no no being authentic
is the point of the game don't worry
whether the stop pouring what other
people call you okay people call you a
motivational speaker Thank You Man I'm
motivated you it's a gift don't get
chopped by their labels stop focusing on
what you want to come across on TV so
would you put more emphasis on
entertainment over information you yeah
I got made that decision myself what
feels right because my main fear is that
I don't want to come across like I don't
care what you're afraid of no in terms
of my videos like I don't care you're
afraid okay doesn't matter what you're
afraid of don't make a decision out of
fear uh-huh it's more like what like I'm
afraid I don't care what you're in a
sense of like that my videos are gonna
make me seem unapproachable I want it
like have a certain image of how I come
across you are you okay stop worrying
about your image yes post your blurry
Instagram pic you're not doing I'm
talking about more for the YouTube I'm
telling you man it's the same thing like
people are gonna the thing that you're
afraid of showing is the thing that's
gonna make people connect you the most
mm-hmm the thing is I don't want to come
across as because in my head I already
know how it is that people have this
idea of a confident guy as is aggressive
overbearing a alpha male type of thing
and I don't want that but at the same
time I want to be like I want myself to
come across relatable while still they
look at me be like I want to be like
that one day so I'm trying to figure out
the best way to stop focusing on what
you want to come across on TV okay there
you go that okay I just own it right
that's it yeah and and when you own the
stuff that you like I'll get up and say
I'm an introvert and like I get nervous
and that just makes me more that's who I
am I am Who I am on my videos as I am
here and you can't handle it you you
think I suck awesome like mm-hmm doesn't
bother me
1% yeah I I just don't want to be I got
posted my store I just wanna be posting
on my feed that's my main thing like
it's your you're in your own head man I
just wanna be posted my feet I was gonna
like I'm just gonna dilute my message
cuz no one heard your said I just people
that I'm interested in and they post
every day and I'm like oh I center post
my name just grow and like I was like
it's the same same stuff every day like
oh I get school I want time okay cool
that's cool message so you only have one
thing to say per month that you can you
can talk about there's nothing that
would dilute in your message it means
you don't have a message to share it's
not so much is this I know the people on
my thing don't care
Wow like you nobody's following you
anyway thanks my friends so like I don't
want to be pulling that from them
because I know they don't they don't
your friends you want to build an
audience and build I want to build it
all you to that's my main focus that's
the thing I'm not this is great yeah and
Instagram is the fastest way to grow
right now you're making seem like if I'm
not posting blurry photos then that's
not then you're not doing you but like
I'm reading into the aesthetic side like
I've been into pictures and stuff and
making nice-looking photos not you want
you like being a pretty I love it yeah
but you want me to take all of that away
just close the door no no it's not
possible airy photo but like it's not me
it's just like what it was was just
gonna do is just um just proves people
that I don't care but now my whole feed
looks off because I have a blurry blurry
photo that doesn't accomplish the
current feed is off your feet right now
is off because that's not you that's a
part of you
you're showing one side of you just like
in these videos when you're being
professional not funny you're showing
that side of you that's the only way you
win you want to unlock winning that's
what it looks like showing you you're
worried about the perception instead of
you just being you in my mind I'm like
I'm trying to be an influencer like all
these guys doing cool stuff like I'm on
my Instagram yeah I understand I am
putting a certain perception but that's
the whole point of the game you wanna
know it's not the point of the game no
no being authentic is the point of the
game I want to win but I would say
there's also me being authentic like I
like me doing stuff and show some of it
but it's not everything of course with
if you want to see that more that goofy
side to go to my stories I'm about
posting me doing some dumb stuff that
feel I want to create such an
inconsistent message nobody wants to
follow you except your friends okay
because you got beautiful pictures and
like oh cool like this guy's fancy
awesome let's see his fancy home when
his fancy cars and then they're like
what am I looking at mm-hmm dude this is
ghetto this is brutal
nobody wants to follow you the way
you're currently doing your strategy
like better if you're gonna go fancy
don't post stories at all unless they're
fancy don't post any content unless
you're fancy yeah I need you the biggest
thing you need to get over is the best
thing that you have is your mind okay
your thoughts your ideas that's what I
want I think you're a genius not because
of how you look but like what's in here
that's what's not coming out and I think
people need that more than once a day I
think people need what's in your head
more than
once a day and so that's why I think I
want to see you on videos more I want to
see you make pictures more I want to see
you right fire captions that's going to
inspire people and don't get caught up
and how many views each ones get because
your views proposals gonna go down for
sure yes sir but your but that's not the
metric your reach is gonna go up your
followers is gonna go up your subscriber
list is gonna go up your email list is
gonna go up your book sales are your
eCourse or whatever you're gonna do is
all going to go up you're attaching it
to the wrong metric people I think
people should hear from you more than
once a day I think you have enough if
you're saying you know I don't have
enough messages like the best I can do
Evan is once a week come up with
something fire to say I think that's BS
I just wanna be a motivational speaker
then don't be a motivational speaker
okay I don't who cares about the labels
be whatever you want to be be a cat
awesome okay what would a cat do like
whatever you want to be do I don't care
don't worry where to stop worrying what
other people call you okay people call
you motivational speaker Thank You Man
I'm motivated you it's a gift okay don't
get trapped by their labels they're
saying you motivated them what's wrong
with that
yeah I just I see people do what you're
telling me to do wrong and then I get do
it wrong right then I feel like if I do
it every day that's the wrong thing
because I'm liking like I wouldn't watch
myself every day unless you write if I
do it good if I do again that's not
gonna be would you watch some would you
watch Will Smith every day if you spit
fire yeah so go be that I wish Will
Smith and he will and he's gonna kill
everybody else you know Smith this fire
and it's and it's a lot of ghetto is him
in his driving and shaking and right and
some of them are nice too some of them
are nice he's got a team and they film
with it's amazing and high produced and
some of it is Will Smith like in your
face yeah and both are great and both as
an expression of him yeah
multi-millionaire super successful in
and down the earth humble as anything
and still want to work hard and crush it
yeah I see that in you man so show me
both sides does mean everything has to
be ghetto grainy terrible yeah but the
most important thing is in the picture
it's the caption protects the mind
what's in your mind if you posted
if you post it everyday with the picture
of this floor every day with a fire
caption your thing would blow up you
genuinely 100% a hundred percent hearty
volunteers percent I don't say anything
I believe okay
hundred percent the floor if you took a
picture of a little filter toilet every
day with fire with like what's in here
you would blow up instead of your once
every two weeks fancy picture with an
with a decent caption yeah I appreciate
that I really do want to win yeah then
then Instagram life needs to be real
life mm-hmm YouTube life needs to be
real life mm-hmm this is how I am done
I've been told people told me you're the
same way videos this is how I am this is
it I'm fire and I'm angry and like I
want you to win and I can be soft and
everything else but this is how I am be
who you are you're you're hitting the
moment why it's okay for you saying
you're saying Instagram is all about
beauty it's like it's part of it but
Will Smith posted a lot of stuff that's
not beautiful but the message is
beautiful I want you having daily
content on Instagram yeah I want you to
one feel like you have a message that
people need to hear mm-hmm that your
message matters mm-hmm I want you to to
then think about daily what kind of
message can I put out that people need
to hear your own confidence and put
yourself in the shoes of all the people
following you commenting the pains are
going through and what they need to hear
today or what you needed to hear when
you were less confident and being picked
on because that guy once a week getting
hit with a message isn't gonna make a
change but once a day will I feel like I
don't have something seen once a day no
but that's what you need to work on you
a thought leader you gotta have
something to say once a day and you do
have something to say once a day cuz
you've said multiple things to all of
these people because i riff off people
without you but fine that's your process
or if riff yeah read through the
comments those are the people riffing
you got comments you got comments and if
it's not on yours go go look at go look
at a Will Smith post and see what people
are posting 1,000 comments is somebody
in there who will spark something that's
the mindset of somebody that you know
and that you need to fix
mmm-hmm I like that I've been trying to
be more authentic over rock I don't you
feel happy overall everywhere every
everywhere and you do such a great job
in person mm-hmm but then you create
personas you got my story persona and my
post persona know personas no judgment
no don't worry about labels you have to
be some some version in different places
there's just add one forever and always
in life on every platform and every
piece of content are you feeling in that
makes no sense yeah I want to show
people more sides can I get people that
look at my photo like oh I thought you'd
be way different in person yeah based
off your photos I thought you'd be a lot
like less like douchebag is we just take
a break what just happen here
what just fun like I'll go view for
maybe the turbot bit here goes like say
I'm gonna be a boy yeah actually pretty
I said pretty boy yeah well you actually
why this is a fright why is this
something come around that you find it
to you know the ball just you just I and
I've been through myself damn this is
how a good boy there's like every girl
thinks I'm a lot of boy why just are you
confused if I just cuz I post those
photos it'll be a show you're going up
I'm only showing that side that's it man
like what are you gonna do man what are
you gonna do now like realization
there's nothing uh-huh so I find out
that I'm not confident awesome what do I
do
what's the action mm-hmm what's the
first knock boy move you're gonna make
for your Instagram it's a probably the
video outside and be like I was nervous
oh and love it though I love it not like
I don't want to hate my Instagram don't
hate that's the you can't hit your
Instagram this is the first because
because Edwin is not a boy mmm-hmm
you're not dude you're awesome
mm-hm that's the one they're like Astro
Boy I've been stressing about like yo
stop stressing you're done you fix it
cuz annoying
you mean it yourself then I did it is
I'll create it but it's like [ __ ]
out the flower [ __ ] okay yeah it's your
different size music keep the apps and
everything else see that that makes
total sense yeah okay so what are you
gonna do you know now it's like Oh show
people with different sizes you stop
being a boy somebody sure in the voice I
put that in your caption yeah Oh ever
said I'm gonna stop being boy or coming
across it's not I'm not being because
I'm
I am just coming okay I hear you okay
come here I got you and that goes back
to what we talked about since I'm not a
boy uh-huh but I get how you can see
that I am one powerful even with the
first thing I told you is like all my
main issues I want people not to like my
videos I think I'm on the approach or on
relatable because the whole point thing
good so you're gonna post a video
tonight sure yeah he's not actually
motivated this alright it's not you
telling you that we kept any much great
and we're done
raise your standard apple at the core
its core value is that people passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
this interview was done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there